with new efforts to make gun violence
the issue a top priority for congress
actor matthew mcconaughey he spoke about
this at the white house with a passion
forged by a personal connection he grew
up in yovalde texas site of the
deadliest mass shooting out of the
dozens we've seen in this country
recently scott mcfarland is on capitol
hill scott good morning are there any
signs of progress
innate here this morning the
negotiations continue but senators
involve warn a breakthrough could take
time in fact a breakthrough is no
certainty and from an elementary school
student to a hollywood actor with an
impassioned plea there's no shortage of
people trying to push the senate to
action
two weeks to the day after the mass
shooting in uvalde the community's most
famous former resident stepped to the
white house podium to talk about the
children's slain and call for gun
legislation this moment
is different we are in a window of
opportunity right now that we have not
been in before
bringing the sneakers worn by
ten-year-old maite rodriguez this is the
same green converse
on her feet that turned out to be the
only clear evidence that could identify
her after the shooting
how about that
making a passionate plea for action like
expanding background checks and raising
the age for purchasing semi-automatic
firearms from 18 to 21. these
regulations are not a step back
they're stepped forward for civil
society and
and the second amendment
democrat chris murphy who is leading
bipartisan senate negotiations he
acknowledges talks have reached a
critical stage with hopes of a proposed
plan by week's end
every day we get closer to an agreement
not further away
republicans have indicated possible
support for tying up loopholes in
background checks and supporting
expanded red flag laws which allow
courts to order guns seized from people
deemed dangerous we're hoping to
actually get an outcome
that will make a difference
in the areas of mental health school
safety and things that are related
to the incidents that occurred in texas
and in buffalo
garnell whitfield jr lost his mother
ruth in the buffalo supermarket shooting
and in testimony before congress had
this message my mother's life mattered
my mother's life mattered
and your actions here today
will tell us how much it matters to you
also here on capitol hill this morning a
fourth grader who survived the uvalde
shooting after smearing a classmate's
blood on her body she'll testify before
a house panel and so will the parents of
a girl slain at that school a very
personal push dana directed at congress
yeah scott we keep saying we keep
hearing people say when will it be
enough perhaps this time people are
listening thank you